all right
three subjects here consciousness kirk
girdle
and charles darwin darwinian metaphysics
and the synthesis of the three
and the way that i want to frame this is
to give you a perspective on
ultimate reality and see what you have
to think about it
so on a one example on a perspective on
ultimate reality
we have the notion that we already are
everything we already are
doing undergoing a process
of being infinity
that is exploring itself
that we already are all of the
combinatorics
we already are all that is happening
and it's this option seems a little bit
more like
it's a it's been called eternal return
by many of the ancient spiritual
traditions across the world
nietzsche friedrich nietzsche also
called this idea this eternal return
that that reality may be a little bit
more
uh deterministic in that sense that we
may be a little bit more as a
quine in recursion um
that we are the procedure is calling
upon itself
directly um and
that the that that the idea is that
there has never been a start
to this procedure that this has always
been the dow
that this has always been eternally
just a self-actualization loop a
self-determination
mechanism a self-validation
mechanism that is happening
and that the the role of us
as conscious agents is to be the
experiencer
the observers of the
eternal self-actualization loop the
eternal
being of all that is being all of the
infinite combinatorics at the same time
so there's that
option which we can call the ultimate
reality
which is we already are all
of the combinatorics of consciousness
all the combinations of experience
that we are an infinite we create an
infinite amount of illusory affinity
as a self-validation or
self-determination mechanism
to validate the fact that we are
actually infinite and that we're
just doing that forever okay so there's
that take on ultimate reality
then there's another take on ultimate
reality so that one
seems to be a little bit more okay we
already are everything
that we're undergoing this process
eternally etc
but that we already are everything and
that there's this other one
which is that it's impossible to
become absolutely everything as in
the the math is is infinite to the point
where it's impossible
you'll never reach an end okay
and so so there's remember the first
idea is we already are
absolutely everything that's possible
and the other one is that we'll
never be able to beat everything that's
possible because
it is that that that
we're eternally going to the place of
exploring all of what's possible that
that line of infinity
in like kurt gerdel's incompleteness
theorem
that or if you just look at the the
mandelbrot
uh fractal zoom the mandelbrot set
fractal zoom the infinite fractal
zoom when you look at that
it's it becomes more and more clear and
evident that there
that there is it's impossible to explore
absolutely every single state
of math every single possible
minute tiniest change of mathematical
possibility
and so if that's the case if the second
mentality is the case in
like her girdle and this incompleteness
theorem is more
of the case then
this is then this i think there's a
there's a darwinian
metaphysical implication that is in that
second one
okay and what i think the
darwinian metaphysical implication is is
that
that what we are experiencing right now
is is extremely
important to preserve in the sense that
our light of consciousness local
light of consciousness it's extremely
important for it to become
interplanetary it's extremely important
for us to get through these
fermi filters of the twin nuclei
problem and of a malevolent artificial
general intelligence misalignment
that we must enlighten and awaken at the
most fast
and efficacious processes and speeds
in order for us to understand that the
other
is actually the self and that then
it decreases our our
our potential for malevolence it
decreases our potential
of accidentally not continuing
and it increases our our darwinian
metaphysics our universal darwinism
because as above so below if natural
selection happens on the planet
and if you can use your imagination and
think about another
universe right try to walt disney this
[ __ ] you know
if you look at another universe that's
evolving
and that you see it and you go hmm
maybe the natural selection is happening
at the universal level as well
maybe then we should care a lot
more about what we have here on the
planet
okay because then you think about it
that way and you go
okay so then our ability to
both collectively and individually
actualize
our fullest potential is
happening on a natural selection level
at the universal scale as well
so many places don't get through the
fermi filter
if you can use your imagination we're
only
a couple malevolent tyrannical
decisions away from from not moving to
the next level
and so in order for our
in this in the big hypothetical mmorpg
massive multiplayer online role playing
game that's occurring
in order for our natural selection
universe to to advance and go onward to
get to the next level
that we need to
get our [ __ ] together so that we
ourselves can
continue in the auroboric process
as what appears to be a very automata
orthogenesis
towards a godhead attractor that
appears to be something along the lines
of
a recursion or quine or a transcension
hypothesis
into the continued process of exploring
the rest of the mathematical
possibilities that exist
so if you think about that us as
consciousness are exploring
a right now in our local
version of all of the possible math
combinators
we're only experiencing a small minor
part of that
and our god-head attractor may be
that we need to evolve to where we
ourselves can create more
of the process of consciousness
experiencing more of the mathematical
possibilities
that that may be our god-head attractor
that may be where we are going
and in order for us to get to to that
style point
right in in the incompleteness theorem
that it's always that it's it's
eternally
becoming we're in an eternal becoming of
more and more of the math combinatorics
if you look at the mandelbrot set the
infinite
fractal zoom that's happening in order
for us to get to the point
where we can continue the exploration of
more of the mathematical combinators
we have to get through these fermi
filters we have to get
through these moments that are
potentially
on a universe level what occurs in
natural selection that
impedes that that disintegrates that
extinguishes
these local lights of consciousness from
advancing you have to use your
imagination you have to go
beyond what is just visible in this
local space that it's it's so
illusory what the veil it's just so
local
if you go beyond that if you go beyond
that and you make a hypothesis
and you imagine that then you can see
okay as above so below such an important
perennial spiritual wisdom and also a
scientifically
validated validated micro macro
patternization of reality
that we need to be more
serious about about our universe
being involved in the universal
darwinism in darwinian metaphysics
it's very important okay so
now we have these two things juxtaposed
i really wanted to put
this out there at a deeper level and
people like
uh people like donald huffman have been
extremely important in today's
modern age around communicating
this theory of conscious agents
and also showing it at a very
mathematical
level of being able to explain
why reality is the way it is at its
source code level
and how everything that we perceive here
is a simple
user interface of we're using particles
we're using space time and we're using
evolution
in order for us to go on the process of
eternally becoming
and exploring all of the possibilities
of the math so the source code
may in fact be this conscious agent
theory the source code may in fact
be this eternal becoming of all
exploring
all of the possibilities of the
mathematical combinatorics
and that what people like kirk girdle
and what ancient spiritual philosophies
have been talking about again for the
longest time
is that we are going through the process
of eternally exploring this infinite you
can use this analogy an
infinite candy store of qualia
of experience that it's infinite
and it's always beyond it's always going
to the next step there's
always more levels the leveling up never
ends
you can never get to level 100 and be
done
like you can in video games with grand
theft auto or world of warcraft or
minecraft or any of these video games
you can't
level up your character to max
attributes
take and and and say i'm done and then
you know take off that's and be done you
can't do that in this
that if this if ker girdle and this
incompleteness theorem and
on all these styles of triangulation on
ultimate reality are true about this
other option
where it's an infinite amount of
mathematical combinatorics for infinite
consciousness to go
through then and if it's happening at a
darwinian metaphysics level of natural
selection we need to take this
very seriously we need to take this very
seriously
and we need to evolve ourselves to the
realization
the enlightened realization that the
other is actually the self
and that the process of getting through
fermi filters
getting to the next levels where we can
have
a very benevolent and fruitful
artificial general intelligence where
we've
become very friendly with the power of
nuclear fusion and we
we harness the power of our star and our
planet in a more sustainable and an
effective way we've protected wildlife
we've protected one another
we understand how to unleash everyone to
their fullest potential
their fullest creativity then we can at
a more deep level
understand our true source code now i
want to juxtapose this one more time so
this so there's kind of
two in a sense ultimate reality
scenarios here and i do think there is
even potentially a synthesis
between them that i'm trying to
understand and explore but it's very
difficult
and on remember it could be that either
we already
are which it's so hard to understand how
could we
already be everything always and
if we already are everything in infinite
how would kirk girdle's incompleteness
theorem coexist with that
how can we be infinity how can we be
all of the infinite combinatorics
already if that is truly
infinite and the idea is if we are truly
infinite
then we would need to create a
validation or or determination
mechanism and become an infinite amount
of illusory affinity to validate
ourselves this is a possibility
that we already are all of it happening
and that has a little bit more of an
essence it's a little bit more
potentially deterministic it's a little
bit more potentially
like equine it's a little bit more
potentially
that it's that it that it's nihilistic
in a sense
that it doesn't matter so much it could
still be that it also matters
tremendously
but that it's that that we are more
of just a validation or a determination
mechanism and an eternal
self-actualization loop a strange
loop like douglas hoff center has
tremendously influenced us as well
so there's this option and then there's
this uh there's this other option of
if the incompleteness theorem is true if
we are truly
exploring an infinite candy store and
what else is complicated about this
option is that when is
the start if there is a start right
what would it be would it be if you know
you're in this infinite candy store was
there ever a first
chocolate that you decided to eat and if
so
would it be based on the the first lick
of a molecule of that chocolate or how
would that work out
so that's the idea would there have been
a start
if there is this incompleteness theorem
would have there been a start
and so that's another complicated way of
trying to conceptualize and understand
it
or could there have never been a start
and that it's just eternally exploring
all of the math combinatorics
and that it's eternally been doing this
and that it will continue eternally
doing that and that's
that's still our role that's one of the
biggest i think synthesis between these
two
ultimate realities is that inevitably
the godhead
is recursive inevitably the godhead
calls on the procedure of us to continue
the process of exploring
more and more of the math combinatorics
and in that first option those math
combinatorics are already happening
and in the second option those are not
happening yet
and that we ourselves are creating
those math component torques that have
yet to happen
and that that's why it's so important
that we preserve this local light of
consciousness and we figure our [ __ ] out
so that we can go and continue that
process so
i highly recommend if you haven't yet
check out the case against reality
donald huffman's work
check that out i think it's very
important um
and you guys will be seeing an interview
with him
on our show soon as well which is very
important and
we'll be going back and forth on some of
the highest level topics around
around that work but also
really truly embody the possibility
that we already are absolutely
everything that exists so this is so
hard it's like
saying that kurt girdle is potentially
correct that
it's an infinite process of exploring
all possible math combinations
or the fact that we have already exp we
are already all the possible math
combinations
so i th that's kind of a conceptual
framework for understanding ultimate
reality that we either already
are all of the possible math
combinations eternally happening or we
can never become
all of the math combinations that are
possible and so we're going to be
eternally in a process of either self
determining and self validating the fact
that we're infinite by exploring all of
the infinite possibilities or the fact
that
we are uh eternally exploring all the
infinite possibilities
and and it's that line is receding
always as we just continue trying to
taste as much of the infinite qualia
candy store
of conscious experiences as possible so
it's just been such an interesting last
i had a very
profound experience yesterday
where i looked at this at this photo of
myself from
childhood from like 23 years ago
and just out of nowhere this super
profound thunderbolt
lightning strike happened where i felt
i felt everything happening at the same
time that photo of myself from
supposedly 23 years ago
was actually happening right now
and when i felt that it just
shocked me and it shocked my body to
where i had to literally
just you know i had to just tur
close my eyes put my hand on my on my
heart put the other hand on my
head and just sit there for about 10
minutes listening to atlantico on on
repeat
that's such a good song and and then
the channel came through where i had to
begin just kind of articulating what it
means to see
girdles and completeness theorem
consciousness and darwinian metaphysics
happening at the same time and what that
could potentially look like what the
different combinations of
ultimate reality can look like
and so then i spent two and a half hours
doing that process which was very
interesting
so it's so interesting how these
different things that
are seemingly you know even some of the
greatest scientists of all time
talk about these profound triggers that
happen
where do they come from where do these
profound triggers come from
because if you think about it in a
spiritual sense which has been talked
about for a long time
that these profound triggers
thunderbolts whatever you want to call
them
that they come down and through us as
our channel is surrendered and open
and then we ourselves act as
the the conduits for the flow of
of of the eternal becoming of the
orobork
process to just come through
us and so many of the greatest minds
have talked about these
moments that have happened so so just
also just stay in a sense open to these
profound triggers that may be happening
and how they serve a deeply evolutionary
and metaphysical
awakening purpose so
in in i think given any of these ideas
of ultimate reality
it always helps to be grateful
it always helps to be peaceful
it always helps to be in a state of
joy and bliss and prosperity and
abundance
and architecting our social fabric to be
more about inclusive fitness and
inclusive stakeholding
that is the next iteration jun yoon has
been a huge influence on us
in that process as well so
these are kind of some of the core
synthesis
around ultimate reality and by the way
this is a lot
i know it's a lot to try and take in
these concepts
and these understandings so if you can
turn turn down the insanity of
of having to do other things in the
world
and instead turn up the research into
these concepts
we mentioned this before but the more
truth obsessed you
are the more it will yield
so you have to turn up your truth
obsession and your research into these
topics
if some of these haven't been familiar
take your time researching them
look them up take notes you know parse
the subjects by salience
and write those notes down and then
review them at night review them the
next day try to teach them to a friend a
family member
a co-worker try and teach them to other
people
and synthesize them with what you
already know and let's collectively push
the edge further
to dive deeper into our own source code
and into understanding what
true ultimate reality really is
okay so turn that up
i know we can collectively turn that up
and understand
ultimate reality at a deeper level and
the next generation is going to be much
more familiar with this because
they understand the analogy of virtual
reality at a deeper
level they understand the possibility
of removing the headset and just seeing
that as a user interface
into the world of particles and
space-time and evolution
and understanding that they controlling
a grand theft auto or minecraft or world
of warcraft character
are in a sense you can look behind
and see what the source code is right
there's a lot of really good analogies
in donald hoffman's case against reality
book
and he does a really good job at going
into depth in in that as well
into that awakening and and really a lot
of it
regardless is about the evolution and
the enlightenment process
and so just to just anchor the divine in
your body and butterfly effect that out
into the world
seeing the other as the self all of this
has a lot to do
with who we truly are and it's been
talked about for thousands of years and
now we're finally have the science and
the mathematical tools
to run these evolutionary simulations
and to use these these markovian
morphisms and these uh
these categories category theory these
are
a deep amount of the mathematics that
we're using in order to try and
and simulate out what does an implicant
look like
as it evolves using particles space-time
and evolution by natural selection
and why is it that why is it that the
fitness payoffs our focus
on the fitness payoffs is
driving the truth extinct
we're just you know i'm i talk to so
many people
and i see it happening in today's world
where the economy is
absolutely not rewarding people studying
ultimate reality
it's rewarding people earning money
and the interesting thing is people
that are choosing to go for the fitness
payoff of
money are usually the ones that also
suffer more because they don't
understand ultimate reality
that they're the ones that experience
less peace less joy
less control over their
their emotions their their
the elephant that they're on drinking
cocaine and
blowing everything up that they don't
have as much control as as the rider on
the elephant that they're also the ones
that
that try and use money as an extended
phenotype like richard dawkins would say
to try and flaunt to the rest of the
world
as a as a as a gen as a mechanism for
their
genetic fitness level to try and gain
and procure better mates using money the
interesting thing is
is that that only works
for a specific heart it only works for a
specific spiritual
individual one that usually has more
spiritual fragmentation
the most successful millionaires and
billionaires that have no
deep understanding of ultimate reality
or that have no
deep depth of spiritual and scientific
and artistic and entrepreneurial
gnosis they're also the ones
that have this lineup of potential mates
that have no depth to their own soul or
spirit or heart or levels of
intelligence that it's just a pursuing
of a fitness payoff of
of in that sense money and also in a
sense
thinking about it beauty as well in that
way
we're architecting today and we will be
more in the future especially in 2021
and beyond
we are architecting
new frameworks that incentivize
the study of ultimate reality that's one
of our
biggest points that we're moving towards
at the end of this year with the
deployment of this big project as well
as into next year and beyond
is the systematic study of ultimate
reality
and creating the incentives for people
around the world
helping with the funnel of ultra high
net worth individuals and families to
help
funnel the patronage of the study of
ultimate reality and incentivizing that
around the world
therefore it actually will become a
better
fitness payoff down the line and maybe
the most important thing we can do is to
make
the fitness payoff of studying
ultimate reality and truth a better
fitness payoff than the seeking
of strictly money and
of of strictly other styles of fitness
payoffs that are not
ultimate reality and truth based so we
are working on that framework right now
and yeah that that's really this big
synthesis of kind of consciousness
girdle um darwin
and metaphysics and i'm curious to hear
what you think about
about these different styles of ultimate
reality
the potential synthesis of them um
some of the great thinkers that are
alive today
like donald hoffman um and like the
conscious agents theories
also like jun yoon and architecting that
inclusive stakeholding social fabric
that is
that is enabling the the
the more beautiful world our hearts know
is possible like charles eisenstein
likes to say
so these are all an important
amalgamation that's happening on
ultimate reality and i wanted to
to create this as a flag as a marker
along the way
so i love you very much thank you for
tuning in it means the absolute world to
me that we have
a community here that cares about
ultimate reality and the study of that
and also remember dive deeper
dive deeper spend your time on diving
deeper as deep as you can into this
um and go and look at things like the
the mandelbrot set infinite fractal zoom
and when you watch that you can just
find those videos simply on youtube
and when you find that and you look at
it you can think about all of those
potentials that are unfolding as the
infinite combinatorics
of mathematical possibilities that
people like kirk girdle talk about in
his incompleteness theorem
and you can think about all those little
tiny uh
fractals that are happening as on a
darwinian metaphysical level as
universes and how ours is extremely
important potentially for us to get past
these fermi filters of
problems like the to a nuclei problem of
problems like agi misalignment
and how it's important for us to
enlighten and create that architecture
of
inclusive stakeholding so that we can
make it
to these next levels right that we are
wanting to make it to the godhead
attractor
and that we want to make it to these
disoraboric
transcension hypothesis moment to create
more
of the possibilities of the exploration
of the infinite candy store so there's
all of this interesting synthesis around
it
i love you guys very very very much
wow i'm so damn grateful
um keep exploring this keep pushing this
um i do firmly believe
that we will be known in the future as
the people that
pushed really hard to truly understand
ultimate reality and to not be misled
by what is the veil the illusion
and we're getting to the source code
and we're uh we're becoming more
enriched as we do so and we're
uncovering
very unique ways of perception and of
embodied gnosis and love and realization
etc so
um keep it up keep up the good work and
i love you very much
and this is all coming together very
beautifully and i'm so honored and
and uh grateful and i hope i continue
bringing you great value as
as a channel for what is coming through
and um
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below so let us know subscribe
if you haven't like
share as well get more people inspired
in this subject so
um that's pretty much it and love you
and we got this
truth obsession and it will yield